eight news now is your local election
headquarters and just
10 votes separate two candidates in one
of our local races that's likely going
to spark yet another election
the i-team's david charns live in studio
following this today closely david
really a tight race yeah it's a type one
here and you can actually count the
difference
between these candidates right on your
fingers we're talking about the race for
clark county commissioner district c
that's on the northwest side of the
valley the seat larry brown holds right
now take a look at this
more than 150 000 votes cast in this
race
and democrat ross miller leads
republican stavros anthony by
those 10 votes today was the deadline
for clark county elections officials to
certify their vote and send it up to the
secretary of state's office
commissioners voted to certify every
race including the presidential race
except this one race here the president
did tweet about this today
now part of the reason is there are more
than 100 discrepancies
in this race those are issues like a
voter who checked in but did not vote
or issues with mail-in signatures
that's the only race in the entire
election where we have any concern
related to the outcome and it's because
of the close margin
it's a district with 218 precincts a
margin of 10
is very difficult elections officials
say a recount would not change the
outcome here so it's likely that just
this one race will head to
a special election we did reach out to
both the miller and anthony campaigns
about what this all means
we've been hearing from everybody across
the entire district
how could this happen you know we voted
for stavros now's your chance you have
to turn out
now we did not hear back from the miller
camp a date for this special election
has not been set and again it would just
be
for this one seat now today we also
learned that six people voted twice in
this election
we do not know the circumstances but
each case will be sent to state
investigators
and those people could be prosecuted
most importantly though
officials say the system worked out and
those votes were caught
i'm david charns 8 news now